you do comedy legs out your former radio
host hopefully you continue with your
radar that's warm that's a good thing
you brought that up because um the the
gentleman that you mentioned on your
radio show today Ronan he will be
helping me and Gary me to do my own
private podcast so we're going to do
that and I should probably start having
some episodes or premiering next we got
a following week and it's about
relationship dating um recipes if you
learn how to want to be a cook um just
pretty much it's like a lifestyle show
so yeah yeah yeah yeah do people come to
you and say how do I be funny how do I
write a joke and what do you tell them
oh you know what so funny some people
said that sometime you have to be born
with the gift um for me I believe that
uh you can it you just have to have an
ear for it or and you have to pretty
much know what's funny um and and some
people definitely have the talent some
people are gifted that way and some
people could basically you can't go up
to uh and practice I mean practice does
build to it if you want to be a comedian
yes you can go to open mics and keep on
practicing and that's how like you have
Jerry Seinfeld and and Richard Pryor
because they you know they go out every
night and do open mics or go on stage
and keep on trying the same and trying
the same show and if you ever seen the
movie the comedian going to the comedy
store or the or the Laugh Factory all
that it's like going to a gym it's just
like keep on practicing um yeah if
you've definitely interested if you
don't have a funny bone and you're not
funny definitely you can go to open mic
at eddie spots you can go on on lines
open mics calm and they'll show you all
the list of places and you can you know
practice your crap if you're interested
in comedy and feel what it's like to
talk in front of a lot of people it's
better than doing a eulogy so yeah
since a lot of comedians come from a lot
of darkness and usually that's how they
developed a skill to be able to make
people laugh yeah yeah what about those
days when things aren't going well you
get that parking ticket Oh somebody cuts
you off in their Beemer on the South
live exactly how do you psych yourself
up it's out of that happy place exactly
um it's it really is i mean comedy is
really it's really it can get really
depressing um which is the worst thing
to have a bar or like to serve drinks to
comedians and you know but yeah I mean
the best comedians they come from pain
um and that's what create laughter me
know being from a family a big family
and being from my family whose choose
Jamaican um you know we came from you
know like about six of us in like a
one-bedroom apartment you know and so
like everybody had to fight for a corner
as a bedroom you know like like that's
how you know taking that pain and making
it funny you know at the at the at the
dinner table and stuff like that so yeah
it really does come from pain um and if
you watch some comedians um you could
see like you know they can keep that
straight face and tell a joke and you're
like that's just funny how come he's not
laughing at that but it's just because
he's taking that pain and and making you
see his reality and making you see his
world so yeah how do you get yourself
booked at comedy clubs in LA are there
open mic nights where you can kind of
try yourself out and you you pretty much
have to be a comedy [ __ ] you have to
really give yourself out for free i mean
seriously until something comes up I
mean that's what I've been doing all my
life until you develop a name and he's
like this kids great and then from there
a manager sees you're an agency's you in
a comedy club and then from there they
represent you and they take ten percent
and a manager take fifteen percent and
they build your name to be the you know
for you to be the next dane cook or the
next Kevin Hart or the next Steve
right you know and how do you not quit
um Eddie Murphy quick comedy because he
he's in the Eddie Murphy Adam Sandler
Rob Schneider a lot of those guys they
they quit comedy because they're really
happy doing the the whole movie process
and the television process um if comedy
is all you love and that's all what you
want you know that's all you want to do
it's so hard to even quit Andrew Dice
Clay he still performs I mean he may not
make people laugh but he just can't give
it up I mean it's just something that
he's just been born with you know that
gift to just just do comedy and that's
all he knows you know